we've got some clouds over on the east
side that's covering up the sun
for now but it is just making for a
beautiful sky if you go to twitter
check out chad graves one of our morning
live photographers and he had on
has a beautiful video of the sky and
sunrise this morning retweet it
and you can always find it through 8
news now as well so
morning temperatures so warm we are
still stuck in the 90s
speaking of boy bands we're stuck in the
90s temperature wise too it's 95
downtown a couple of neighborhoods have
some upper 80s like centennial hills
aliante summerlin
mid 80s out at red rock outside the
valley 80s and 90s low 90s for boulder
city mid 90s for laughlin triple digits
for death valley
when you're 122 degrees for the
afternoon high it's a little hard to
cool off overnight
60s cali any in cedar city feels good
wouldn't it be nice to put a jacket on
if it gets too cold inside with the air
conditioning i guess you could wear some
long sleeves 54 up at ely
70s in tonopah we're still still under
those excessive heat warnings these
will last all the way until monday
evening
with heat advisories for the mountains
so please just take care of yourself
take care of
anyone on medication the elderly the
very young very susceptible to heat
illness
and the pets hopefully are staying
inside where it's nice and cool
with you in the air conditioning high
pressure set up over northern arizona
into southern nevada
to really drive those temperatures up
the radar is showing that there is a
little surge of some monsoon moisture
into northwest arizona and the lower
colorado river valley could see some
isolated thunderstorms there today and
tomorrow
they won't make them as far north as the
las vegas valley even our mountains will
stay
with some hot sunshine near 90 up there
at mount charleston
114 for the valley again today
likely a new record high uv index of 11
plus
oh my goodness the numbers keep going up
for the weekend 116
115 114 monday trading some heat for a
little humidity and maybe some
thunderstorms overnight
early next week and i only mean a slight
trade 107 looks pretty good doesn't it
nate i don't know about